when we decided to launch the campaign
publicly which was in October of 1992 at
the offices of Human Rights Watch in New
York a small group of NGOs came together
representing mine clearance victim
assistance
Human Rights Watch which was doing
groundbreaking research on the long-term
impact of landmines on civilians I at
that time was working for the Vietnam
Veterans of America Foundation
coordinating the campaign we you know
the reason we took it up was because
there were landmines in 80 or 90
countries around the world every 20
minutes somewhere in the world there was
a new land mine victim either killed or
maimed because landmines were being
produced and sold like any other
commodity and we found it appalling that
once you sit down for 30 seconds and
think about maybe a landmine helps the
military for two weeks or something or
two hours of the battle
but then they go away and they lead them
there and then for generations literally
people will die when there's no war how
can any humane and human person think
that is okay so we launched the campaign
we were phenomenally successful had the
treaty within five years of the launch
now I think it's 160 nations that are
part of the mind being treaty it is one
of the most complied with and followed
treaties in the world there used to be
20,000 new victims a year I'm pretty
sure that was the number now it's down
to four thousand that is still four
thousand too many but it shows the
impact of this campaign that it has
dropped that much that many countries
have now in place national mind
clearance plans and action
there are several countries and I wish I
could remember which ones but I can't
who have cleaned all the mines out of
their territory
they're now mine free none of that would
have happened without ordinary people
seeing a problem and deciding that they
had the right and the obligation
to get up off their ass and come
together and work to change the world on
this one little topic and in addition to
all the good things that it has done in
in the world of getting rid of landmines
I think an equally profound result of
our campaign was showing ordinary people
around the world that you actually can
you can if it's we not me
if we come together with a common goal
we can contribute to peace granted
landmines are one small part but it sent
a huge signal
that people everywhere can come together
can focus on one goal you can still do
your other work I mean human rights
watch is gigantic they didn't stop all
their other work but the weapons
division became involved been the same
with many of the organizations you know
we focused on a goal we found countries
that shared the same goal and we did the
seemingly impossible and it made you
know ordinary people everywhere believe
Wow Wow you know we can do it